well you guys know Grant Cardone yeah
who doesn't and one day I told Grant you
gotta quit with all these posts bro
because I get a little piece of of their
revenue and it would hurt me if they
were hurt so like Grant just kept
posting and posting and posting and he
was on everything like a new app came
out there was Grant and I'm like
Jesus dude stop already people are gonna
get sick of you you're gonna ruin your
brand you're gonna cost us all money you
need to stop you need to stop you need
to stop you wouldn't stop as you know
boom boom in your face all day every day
I called him one day I said Grant I'm
gonna have to unfollow you dude I'm
serious I'm gonna unfollow you you know
what he said he said go ahead you ain't
buying anything anyway
Grant built his whole entire personal
brand from posting videos online every
single day in your face all day every
day and he doesn't give a rats if you
like him or don't like him